go down an adventure today I'm gonna let
Twitter make all my decisions for me I'm
gonna send out a question they're gonna
send out responses I'm gonna pick the
two best and then I'm gonna have people
vote and then I'm gonna do things I woke
up in the morning like any old boy would
and I'm like I gotta have breakfast
today why don't I let Twitter decide
what I eat for breakfast I think they're
gonna choose pancakes and bacon but
maybe they'll choose the healthy option
for me so I can stay skinny they chose
pancakes and bacon over avocado toast
before I left the house I had one more
quick question trying to make the bed or
not they're like don't yeah whatever I'm
away to house the pies I supplies out
supplies came in and no one spoke to me
I got my pancakes and bacon I don't
really like pancakes I felt terrible
stairs most of the internet either
wanted me to [ __ ] with Ned or they
wanted me to go up and hug people kiss
people so I sent out a poll they chose
[ __ ] with Ned poor Ned I took Ned's
keyboard and mouse Ned you look at you
looking for your mouse a keyboard Turner
wants me to get a makeover instead of
wear my clothes backwards I would have
chose clothes backwards Collin at the
same time is producing a video called
hand food roulette
condensed milk that is the worst thing I
could get I'm lactose intolerant and
that's just triple milk this dairy on
top of the bacon and pancakes is
starting to make a set of mistakes that
have come into play later oh now I'm
gonna go get a makeover so we're using
that foundation make it look like I'm
trying to be a different race let's
let's skip that okay she's a very nice
Latina girl and she gives me very nice
Latina girl makeup the same makeup on
two different faces we look exactly the
same realizing my beauty I gotta take
this out to the public looking so fresh
so fine about to go narrate some people
as they live their everyday life we can
go out this door right yeah great she
walked out barely noticing him earbuds
in sipping her coffee didn't cause a
stir in her that he looks so beautiful
most people completely ignore me you
know either they heard me and decided
not to approach the man in crazy-looking
makeup or they just didn't hear me
until a very nice lady who actually was
also latina so maybe that maybe that is
why she strode confidently down Sunset
Boulevard stopping for a second backing
up what's going on walking a little bit
more enthusiastically she continued
through waved at a stranger continued on
hands on hip couldn't stop her it's her
Wednesday
it's her Wednesday hey do you what are
you doing right now I'm doing a thing
today where I let Twitter control
everything that I do well you're going
to sugar fish should I ask Twitter if I
go with you yeah I have a delightful
sushi lunch with her and her friend
however raw fish on top of the dairy and
the pancakes and bacon my stomach is
torn apart
I am farting
that gets in on the bun and decide to
enter the party I'm not fit against the
rules
yeah I know I do so it's a small guy you
know what I don't feel bad about it
cause Zach really needed to work out
some knots in his back oh right there
yeah yeah yeah
I'm not gay ah he's a wound up little
boy I'm on my way to get some rotisserie
chicken which I'd normally be thrilled
about except that I'm still wearing this
goddamn makeup because Twitter won't let
me take it off you did this to me
Twitter I will say though you guys made
the right call so as I leave the Middle
Eastern restaurant in my stomach I have
half a chicken raw fish condensed milk
and pancakes and bacon everything
decides it's time to leave this is bad
everybody I gotta poop really bad and
I'm driving almost there almost there
you're gonna text Alex I have to poo I
get there in time thank God I poop the
kind of poop you don't want to talk
about and then I get ready to lay down
some sick Rap Tracks
yeah yes cuz here she about to lay down
some sweet lyrics Twitter decided and
also I still got some piggies it's a
really cool song I'm writing you'll see
it soon I'm almost done in my day like
alright time to head home I ask again
however if I can take off my makeup
they're like nah I get home and Becky's
upset what were you just mad at me about
is you had to make the banner
it wasn't my father was Twitter's bones
I think that she's gonna be like Keith
get that makeup off of you however
moral of the story I don't know if there
is one I found out that I have a lot of
lady sorter followers and they love the
idea of keeping me at makeup forever
should you let Twitter run your day all
the time probably not will you have the
opportunity to discover new things and
become a Latina lady
probably
that's it